the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program in the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grand Master
varuja nicobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between at-risk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2019 the St
Louis chess club has also created a
chess merit badge for the scouts BSA
quickly becoming one of the most popular
badges with more than 2 250 000 Scouts
earning the badge since 2011. students
of chess can also pick up a copy of read
and write Jess thanks to Club co-founder
Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield anyone can
learn how to understand chess notation
in no time we view chess as a valuable
educational tool learn more about our
Scholastic programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]